I can't believe it hardly any women
study engineering sciences at German
universities thinks like information
technology for instance
[Music]
time and again I hear talk about more
women wanting to work in IT
yet only one in four sitting here is a
woman why is that do we have to
reprogram society girls have been
playing soccer and boys wearing thing
for a while now but when it comes to
studying the professions they still live
in different worlds
[Music]
professor uliana zika race is trying to
change that by teaching IT to women only
[Music]
why are women not interested in IT
holland and women are interested they
just don't know it yet they deal with it
every day but they don't realize it's IT
when they use their cell phone when they
use a ticket machine or when they drive
a car how do you bring women to study 18
we attract them by saying that we start
at zero other subjects do that too but
it has more credibility in an
environment where only women are
studying and it lowers the inhibitions
that students have when they think there
are prerequisites for study in IT our
second slogan is please ask questions we
encourage our female students to
question everything and it works the
atmosphere is much more interactive than
in our co-ed study programs the students
aren't as afraid to ask questions
if women don't get into programming we
won't be able to shape the world what
effects could that have that would be
drastic because our lives are governed
more and more by IT there will be hardly
any areas left where IT doesn't play a
role when women help develop it they
have more of a stake in it and they are
more qualified for the professions that
will be left if women don't help shape
it they're shutting themselves out on
Vanhorn business Milligan don't listen
to disturb hours you know what I think
so few women are visible in engineering
and IT they think it's not the world I
want to live in a world in which women
develop the technologies in which women
also shape the future
[Music]